what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder we just got a new
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania and it did not disappoint in the
slightest we got a very very good look
at Kang the Conqueror who is not only
going to be the main villain of Ant-Man
3 but also the main villain of this
entire Multiverse Saga so this is going
to be the big bad of the MCU for the
next few years much like Thanos was for
the infinity Saga Kang is the villain
from the Multiverse Saga and Ant-Man is
when we are really going to get
introduced to the true king the
Conqueror for the very first time we did
meet a variant of Kang and Loki he who
remains and he said that of Loki and
Sylvie killed him his variants were
coming and he said that they were much
more evil and as we can tell from this
trailer they absolutely are so in this
breakdown of the new Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania trailer we'll talk a
lot about King but also talked about all
the very important and details that you
need to know to understand everything
that is happening in this trailer and in
the film also if you're new to the
channel and you love Marvel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so much like the first trailer that
we got it opens up with Scott Lang kind
of being famous now he is a famous
Avenger so his life is a little bit
different after Avengers end game
rightfully so he did help save the
entire universe and what's interesting
is the trailer opens up with dialogue
from Kang stating you're an Avenger but
interestingly enough the second thing he
says is you have a daughter it then
shows Scott checking his phone he is
getting a call from his daughter Cassie
Lang but notice it's still a picture of
her as a baby now we know from Avengers
in-game thanks to the five-year Gap when
Scott saw her last time she was very
very grown up as she is in this trailer
in fact she is calling him because she's
in jail and she needs her dad to come
bail her out but he keeps that picture
because that's kind of the daughter that
he knew he lost five years with his
daughter which is what king is actually
referring to with his dialogue here when
he says you have a daughter her but
you've lost a lot of time like me now
we're gonna go into what like me means
in just a bit but first let's talk about
Scott losing a lot of time of course
it's referring to that five-year Gap now
unfortunately during that five-year Gap
Cassie didn't have a father and we know
thanks to some plot details that have
gone around about this movie that Cassie
is kind of getting in trouble as we can
see in this because she went to jail and
Scott is desperately trying to make up
for the time that he lost with her when
he was stuck inside of the quantum realm
for five years and Scott is trying to
make up for that time which is why Kang
says we can help each other with that we
then see a footage of Scott and Cassie
being sucked inside of the quantum realm
but we also know thanks to the first
trailer that came out not only them got
sucked in but of course Janet Van Dyne
Hank Pym and the WASP gets sucked in as
well this is due to a device that Cassie
has created that allows them to
communicate with people inside of the
quantum realm they sent down a message
and ended up getting sucked in so now
they're all stuck this is where Scott
meets King and this is where King's
proposition comes in of course Scott
does not know who came the Conqueror is
it's just a random person that he's met
inside of the quantum realm Scott asks
who are you in which king replies I'm
the man who can give you the one thing
you want time now King the Conqueror in
the comics is a time traveler he is the
master of time he's conquered endless
worlds using time travel but not just
worlds in our universe worlds and other
universes as well and that is
essentially what king the Conqueror
wants to conquer the entire Multiverse
but due to the fact that Kang can time
travel and he can actually travel
through different universes is why he is
so dangerous and we actually hear Janet
Van Dyne talk about how dangerous he
actually is she says he can rewrite
existence in shatter timelines now she
knows who he is because she was stuck in
the quantum realm for many many many
years up until Scott and Hank and the
WASP rescued her but due to her being
stuck for many many years she ran into
King the Conqueror this is why she knows
about how powerful he is so King the
Conqueror can use time travel to go back
at any point in time in any different
timeline in any different universe and
to send eventually rewrite history or
completely destroy a timeline much like
the TVA did the TVA would go into
timelines that were branched out and
they would destroy them but remember he
who remains who is a variant of King
created the TVA so Kang has the ability
to completely destroy timelines however
he also has the ability to rewrite them
and this is what is appealing to Scott
Kang is going to lie to Scott and tell
him that if he helps him he can give him
back time the time that he missed with
his daughter during the blip Which Scott
desperately wants this is also why Scott
says I don't care who he is I've just
lost so much he can give us a second
chance and of course that second chance
is not only the time that he missed with
his daughters but also the time that he
missed with Hank and Janet and hope the
people that he loves he wants that time
back now during this dialogue we get a
look at Kang's city which is called
chronopolis in the comics now what's
really interesting is that in the comics
chronopolis exists outside of space and
time just like the quantum realm does
this is actually why Kang chooses to
build his base inside of the quantum
realm because through the quantum realm
he can travel through any point in time
which is why he chose to establish his
base here now if you notice a lot of the
city a lot of its buildings and
platforms seem to be in a circular shape
they almost look like Gears of a clock
resembling time you'll also notice that
these rings and the markings on these
Rings look very familiar as well in fact
they look like the tin rings from Xiang
Chi and the legend of the tin rings in
the post-credit scene of Chongqing the
legend of the tin Rings Wong was
investigating the Rings Bruce Banner and
Carol Danvers were also looking at them
trying to figure out where they came
from and they said that it's alien it
doesn't seem like it's from Earth
however it could be from Earth but a
Earth from Another Universe or the same
Earth from the future but it is believed
that the Mandarin chongqi's father could
have possibly gotten the Rings from King
however he got them it does seem to be
Kang technology the same goes with
Kamala Khan Miss Marvel's Bengal and
since the whole entire Saga is about
King all these mystical and magical
items are eventually going to come
together when we finally get at the Kang
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars now
Janet is absolutely terrified of King
because she knows what he can do and she
says you cannot trust this man however
Scott pretty much says I don't care who
he is it seems like he can give me back
what I lost time a time with my daughter
time with hope time with you so at first
Scott is going to agree to try and help
Kang now as far as why we'll talk about
that in just a second but first let's
check out this scene that is super super
interesting we see Ant-Man kind of split
into two here and this is super
interesting because it looks like it's
creating a variant on the spot now
typically we have variants because the
Multiverse exists inside of the MCU
therefore different Earths exist
therefore different variants of the same
character exist but we've never seen
anybody split in half before now I'm
sure we're gonna speculate and theorize
a lot on what could actually be
happening but just given this first look
that we got here I think Scott splits in
half because time sort of splits in half
through him because remember from
Avengers endgame Tony Stark said that
you could send time through a person
instead of sending a person through time
therefore I believe that two Scots could
have been created based off of how time
works inside of the quantum realm we've
heard that many times we've heard it
from Janet and Scott say time works
differently in the quantum realm I
believe that these are going to be Scots
who are going down different paths
inside of the quantum realm this is how
we're going to get it looks like
thousands of different ant-mans and it
looks like sadly a few of them if not
many of them are not going to be making
it out alive so we will see Ant-Man die
in this movie we've actually already
seen a variant of Ant-Man die much like
as I've been saying Reed Richards of the
Illuminati and Multiverse of Madness but
I'm assuming we're going to see a lot of
other different variants of Ant-Man die
as well however I'm hoping our main
variant of Ant-Man stays alive now as to
why Kang needs ant-man's help well that
is because this king is actually a
variant of King and most likely not the
one who is in charge of this big city
that we see based off of what we know
about the plot for this movie there's
going going to be at least two kings and
one of them is going to be stuck inside
of the quantum realm with no way to get
out which is why this Kang says you've
lost a lot of time so have I this is
because he is stranded inside of the
quantum realm because he does not have a
power source for his time chair now in
the comics Kang's time chair is his time
travel device that's how he goes through
different timelines into different
universes so Kang is stranded inside of
the quantum realm and based off of what
we know the only way he can get out is
if he gets a power source to power his
chair and he needs to steal that from
his other variant who is essentially the
ruler of the quantum realm the person in
charge of this huge City it's
essentially a heist a robbery which is
why Ant-Man is perfect that is what he
used to do when he was a criminal
however Kang doesn't exactly give him a
choice he tells Ant-Man let me make this
easy for you you will bring me what I
need referring to the power source or
everything you call life will end so
Scott really doesn't have much of a
choice because as you can tell here from
the trailer Kang is extremely powerful
full and could pretty much wipe Ant-Man
away easily so Ant-Man decides to kind
of trust him because he wants time back
but then of course Kang being the
villain will end up betraying him which
is why we hear Ant-Man say we had a deal
now there are three more very important
parts of this trailer that we need to
talk about the first one being modak the
first time we see him he's actually kind
of hidden in the back and we see him
without any type of shielding over his
face if you freeze frame at 57 seconds
in the trailer you can clearly see him
and as you can tell he is working for
King however you probably know who Modoc
actually is they are changing this from
the comics this is actually Darren cross
from the very first Ant-Man movie
otherwise known as the villain
yellowjacket at the end of Ant-Man we
knew that he pretty much got sent inside
of the quantum realm and from there
somehow he is turned into Modoc which is
an acronym that stands for mechanized
organism designed only for killing and
if you freeze frame at 57 seconds like I
said you could take a look at his face
and it does look like Dan across but we
also get another look at him at one
minute 45 seconds and we can see him in
Full Armor All meched Out and I gotta
say I was kind of worried about the
design however after seeing him without
the helmet on without the armor on he
looks great he looks like the comic
accurate modak and then when he puts the
armor on he looks insanely menacing like
a True Villain so I'm actually liking
this but hey let me know what you think
down below now the second important
thing we have to finish off with is this
so-called power source that Scott is
trying to take now first of all it looks
like him and a bunch of these other
variants that are probably going to be
created while he is inside of the
quantum realm it looks like they're all
trying to get it together but there are
a couple of things to notice about this
we saw the power source in the very
first trailer we saw Kang put it inside
of some device it could have actually
been one of the guns that he uses
however it does look like King the
Conqueror has a giant power source that
he uses to power his entire city and I
believe this is what we are seeing that
is kind of floating in the air that has
all of the Rings circling around it this
seems to be what the giant ant pile is
trying to grab and it looks massive but
if you notice the 120 Mark Scott is
holding his arm up to it like he is
about to fire a Pim disc at it this
would in turn shrink the power source so
Ant-Man could grab it and take it back
to the other king or if at this point in
time he's already realized that the
variant of Kang is evil try to take it
to stop him but this could actually be
the very specific reason that Kang needs
him to steal it because the power source
is huge and this stranded King might not
have the technology to shrink it down
however Ant-Man does he has the pen disc
that can shrink it but the part two to
this is I think that these other Ant-Man
variants might actually turn on him as
soon as he gets the disc I think they're
going to want it for themselves because
if they are any type of variant of him
they're gonna think the same way which
is why I believe that we are seeing all
of these ant-man's pile on top of him
but of course the last thing that we
have to talk about is how insanely
awesome and Powerful Kang really is now
in the beginning we see king with a
helmet on with a mask on and that mask
covers him and he looks blue much like
Kang does in the comics now this is
armor that he has actually designed off
of Dr Doom's armor in the comics after
going backwards in time to ancient Egypt
and being defeated by The Fantastic Four
he then goes to the 20th century where
he actually meets Dr Doom and depending
on which storyline you go by in the
comics he could actually be an ancestor
of Doctor Doom himself but his Centurion
armor is based off of Doctor Doom it's
incredibly powerful and pretty much
impenetrable because you see the reason
Kang is so powerful isn't because he
himself actually has any type of powers
naturally the reason he is so powerful
is essentially because he is the master
of time travel he can go to different
points in time past present but most
importantly future and take all of their
technology any type of advanced Weaponry
he can take so he is essentially turned
time travel into Tech that he can use to
control time we saw this in Loki we saw
he who remains know every attack from
Loki and Sylvie so he would use the
device ice on his arm to avoid them and
essentially teleport so through his
technology he has amazing abilities in
the comics Kang's technology is actually
from the 40th Century so hundreds of
years in the future and Kang is actually
a genius himself so he uses all of this
technology to basically be able to
control time and on top of that the
technology that he has gives him
Incredible strength the ability to
harness and use energy as a weapon plus
not to mention it can create a force
field around him that is basically
impenetrable he can create Holograms
with this technology as well and to top
it all off his technology can also
control other technology and to really
top it all off he is an expert in
hand-to-hand combat we see that at the
end here King is really really whooping
on Ant-Man and we see him put him in an
arm lock a headlock and basically just
beats him down he even kicks him in the
head crushing his helmet so he's pretty
much really hard to beat plus not to
mention in the comics he can transfer
his Consciousness into another body of
his a different variant of his so you
kind of really can't kill him which is
what I'm I'm assuming is kind of going
to happen here at the end of this movie
so he's basically unbeatable which is
why Kang says you thought you could win
but it looks like Ant-Man has a plan
because he says I don't have to win we
both just have to lose this we will
definitely be coming up with some
theories about so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of those videos
and in the meantime let me know what you
thought about this trailer I thought it
was amazing but leave your thoughts and
comments down below and of course if you
caught anything you think we might have
missed leave that in the comments as
well you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign